I am going to turn then to Seth Kalesh
Minh some of you know Seth Seth is our
plenary speaker this morning his bio is
in your packet so you can get the the
full information on his background or
some of it I imagine that there's a lot
more to say about Seth and we've
included in this scant biosketch Seth is
a professor in the Department of
Psychology at the University of
Connecticut he also holds a position as
director of share working on HIV
research in an organization that's
located in atlanta i believe and his his
research has focused on both prevention
and care for people with HIV he has
worked mostly in the south in this
country and also in South Africa he has
published prolifically prolifically he
has over 200 peer-reviewed publications
and has received multiple distinguished
awards so I am happy to introduce Seth
and to say that I think that the topic
that he is presenting this morning I
know is of keen interest to everyone
here it's almost unfathomable to think
that people would deny the existence of
AIDS and dissuade people from receiving
testing and counseling and care but in
fact that is happening right here in the
United States now other countries and
that is the topic of Seth's presentation
so Seth would you come up thank you
well thank you very much I really want
to thank first off Sarah I the lights
going to be dimmed if they are to be
great like to thank Sarah for organizing
this incredibly beautiful book launch
for me of course no one at syrah knows
that this is a book launch for me but
they do now and what I'm going to talk
to you about today is a topic that is I
think interesting but should be of
greater interest and so to start I
thought I would start with a quote from
really one of them one of the more
famous and well-known mathematicians of
his time Serge Lang who was here at Yale
he he died relatively recently but Serge
Lang was a advocate and an activist for
intellectual freedom in science and he
among his many quotes that are relevant
to this talk today Serge Lang said I do
not regard the causal relationship
between HIV and any disease is settled
and this was like in 1994 I have seen
considerable evidence that highly
improper statistics concerning hiv/aids
have been passed off as science and that
top members of the scientific
establishment have carelessly if not
irresponsibly join the media in
spreading misinformation about the
nature of AIDS we just don't really know
that much about HIV and can't conclude
that it cleanses AIDS deal professor in
mathematics
but we all know that HIV causes AIDS
right doing everything that we know
about AIDS and everything that we
believe about HIV causing AIDS is why
we're all here today right it directs us
towards testing I've picked up a
pamphlet there are many of them outside
the door urging people to get tested
which directs us towards treatment which
directs us towards prevention right
that's our world right well what if
everything that we think we know about
AIDS actually isn't true now it
throughout this entire presentation I've
got a lot of graphics they're all taken
from the internet get it I didn't make
any of them up there's an organization
called rethinking aids and and they say
that there are over 2,000 scientists and
they list their names on their website
scientists professionals academics that
are on record as questioning the very
theory that HIV causes AIDS so they say
that many experts contend that aids is
not fatal incurable or caused by HIV
they say that most AIDS information we
receive is based on unsubstantiated
assumptions unfounded estimates and
improbable predictions and they say that
symptoms that are associated with AIDS
are easily treatable actually by
non-toxic the immune boosting herbal
natural means now we often associate
this movement and it is a movement with
a biologist at the University of
California Berkeley Peter duesberg
because he was not the first but among
the first and certainly the most
credible and certainly the most visible
scientists to question the link between
HIV and AIDS
Peter duesberg is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences he was
appointed to the national academy of
sciences because he was one of the he
was the first scientist to map the first
oncogene the first cancer-causing gene
it is a lifetime appointment once you're
in the National Academy of Sciences they
can't take that back shortly after this
discovery a Peter duesberg recanted and
said you know what I was wrong and
actually there is no genetic basis for
cancer oh and by the way retroviruses
like that HIV that Gallo says he
discovered they cannot cause disease and
he said both of those things in one
article published in perspectives in
cancer research very esteemed but I
think it's always best to let these guys
sort of speak for themselves so this is
a an excerpt let's Peter duesberg tell
you himself scientists in this country
and signs in the world is to beat
Democratic all voices could be heard to
find the truth in particular if you
don't have the tools if so if hypothesis
as toe is as totally bankrupt as the
virus hypothesis that hasn't saved one
single life we are killing hundred
eighty thousand people who is a CT we
are paying an army of fifty two hundred
thousand scientists who could not even
predict the spread of AIDS that is the
time to say where's our market economy
does that make sense is the patient
getting its dollars worth of treatment I
the answer is clearly no there is no
hypothesis is in biology that has been
so unproductive so unable to predict
anything as the virus eight hypothesis
it is time to stand up and say to call
for alternatives but it's difficult to
do in our country because medical
science is now a totalitarian field it
is entirely regulated the money is
entirely distributed from one
institution that's a National Institute
of Health and they have made up their
minds before even one paper had been
based on the subject in 1984's we
discussed half an hour ago when Reagan
was to be reelected and gallo and
Margaret heckler announced the cause of
AIDS have been found before one single
study had been published the papers that
had subsequently be published by gallo
will wear since all shown to be
fortunate replicate replicating with you
ok so what most of you probably believe
right is that HIV enters the body it
causes an immediate immune response but
the immune system can't suppress it we
produce antibodies but they don't really
work against the virus and over a long
period of time years HIV causes disease
ultimately AIDS which is
life-threatening you know but that's
wrong ok duisburg says that's wrong so
what what actually is the duesberg Ian
explanation then while it's actually
quite different ok he doesn't dispute
that aids exists but what causes AIDS
are environmental toxins poisons that
are in the environment the foods that we
eat poverty stress and antiretroviral
medications themselves drugs themselves
heroin poppers those are the causes of
AIDS and they are coincidental with
finding HIV antibodies in a person and
most of you think that what happens with
when HIV enters a cell is it takes over
the cell and kills T cells but that's
wrong actually HIV is a harmless
passenger virus it's coincidental many
of us have it we produce antibodies it
does not mean that we will develop AIDS
we develop AIDS if we live in poverty if
we abuse drugs once we test HIV positive
because we're put in those risk group
categories we start taking those toxic
poisons particularly AZT because you
know AZT is a toxic poison it's a DNA
terminator
how could it not kill you there have
been a lot of books written on
alternative theories of AIDS and tell
you the things that I'm summarizing here
there were three books written in the
last couple of years these theories and
perspectives on AIDS get into the mass
media most visibly a full spread article
in harper's magazine in 2006 Discover
Magazine has done a couple of full page
spreads on Peter duesberg and his work
most recently in 2008 mothering magazine
we see these ideas coming into the
mainstream media through a couple of
primary outlets but mass media magazines
published particularly by the Guccione
group there are full-length feature
films on alternative perspectives on
AIDS here is a trailer for an upcoming
film
do you remember Ryan White Ryan White
was born a haemophiliac in 1971 he
received numerous blood transfusions for
his condition in December of 1984 he
tested positive for HIV the virus
scientist claimed caused AIDS Ryan White
began to take powerful and poisonous
drugs to combat the virus including a
failed cancer drug known as a AZT Ryan
White lived his life on the run
ostracized by friends and neighbors for
his diagnosis Ryan White never had a
girlfriend Ryan White never grew up and
had a career a home and a family of his
own in 1990 at the age of 18 Ryan White
died in a hospital bed when he was
buried Ryan White was called a hero in
the battle against AIDS the only problem
is Ryan White did not die of AIDS Ryan
White was murdered
now I have to tell you a rather careful
Google search finds no website for a
movie called do no harm and the
production company I can find that
either so I'm not so sure that there's a
feature film coming but there may be
because they're about a half a dozen
others mostly produced on by a guy named
Gary Null where we see most of this
stuff is on the internet and it's
actually quite visible any google search
having to do with anything looking for
aids information it's going to pop up
multiple possible websites some of them
are much more visible than others
rethinking aids and alive and well are
probably the most visible but there are
multiple websites from around the world
on every continent except for Antarctica
yet so far so what is this stuff well it
really is the nihilism I came what in
denialism is differentiated from the
Nile we all know that denial is a
psychological process that people go
through when they're facing a traumatic
event and they just can't face reality
but ultimately they snap into reality
it's it gives us a kind of a buffer
period a period of time where we can
sort of adjust right that's denial
denial is improper gates myths and
essentially creates a facade of reality
that doesn't line up with the facts
while disputing and refuting the facts
AIDS denialism is just one type of
denialism very famous is holocaust the
nihilism the Holocaust didn't happen
it's a it's a contrived lied to justify
the existence of the State of Israel 6
million Jews just really weren't killed
911 denialism or 911 truth-seeking same
thing is another example Global the
global climate change denialism isn't
example there is actually a flat earth
society there is a group of people
that's still claim that it is a hoax
that the earth is a sphere and there are
people that belong to the Flat Earth
Society and I know you think I'm making
this [ __ ] up but I'm telling it let me
tell you a little bit more about this
because what we've done here has
experienced a I think we've experienced
a computer freeze okay
this is going to take me a minute
less than a minute
so most of the stuff is found on the
internet and that normally you know
there's sort of like the Internet's a
wild wild west right and so we often
don't pay attention to sort of the junk
that's out there and resumes lie Joe
yeah okay and that's been part of the
problem is that we have ignored this
stuff but it is rampant particularly on
the Internet i want to show you this
brief it's a it's about four or five
minute snippet that gives you a sense
for a lot of the key players and what
they're telling people the doctor says
okay yes we you have here sick people
and we treat them who try to treat them
but we only treat them because we hear
from them they have a deadly virus not
because they're sick most of them are
come completely healthy which would say
just the face too much people come in
they're taking the medications and
they're looking bronze their skins
turning plenty colors they're real
niemiec they're weak sometimes coming
with canes they do a little research on
their own we don't tell them what to do
we're about self-empowerment self
responsibility taking charge of your
life and health they begin doing that
they get off your medications color
starts coming back they start putting on
the weight they start feeling better but
there's a lapse that get afraid again
they start taking medications we watch
them start shrinking up again they start
looking gone they start getting pale
again they start getting real quick then
they go maybe I should be doing this
they get off they start coming back
again you actually watch this and it's
coordinated with taking these
medications this is unmistakable when
biggest thing that's missing in science
today's common sense 1987 was the year
that there was a big rise in the
mortality rates of HIV positive
hemophiliacs 1987 was also the year that
AZT was introduced as a therapeutic for
AIDS and also administered to
hemophiliacs or HIV positive and I'm
pretty
convinced that the rise of the mortality
of these haemophiliacs is a direct
consequence of the toxic effects of the
AZT AZT was so toxic in the 1960s that
it was never used in humans in fact it
was so toxic it was considered worthless
that's why they didn't even patent it
I'm also concerned with the growing
number of states that are passing laws
requiring pregnant women to be tested
for antibodies to HIV following the
passage of these laws it's a short step
to compelling or intimidating these
women to take these poisons and also to
give these poisons to their babies when
a woman is pregnant in this country
she's told not to be around cigarette
smoke drink coffee alcohol yet we're
telling a woman who test positive on a
nonspecific test for antibodies that may
or may not have anything to do with HIV
that the only reasonable response is to
take a drug that terminates DNA changes
they're forming that causes immune
suppression anemia seizures
muscle-wasting that causes damage to the
mitochondria of the cells that has been
shown to produce infants with incredibly
horrible boost effects ranging from
webbed fingers to miss shapen heads to
holes in their chest to mental
retardation this is wrong women who test
HIV positive and are pregnant are having
their children taken away from them or
being threatened with loss of custody if
they don't comply with what the Centers
for Disease Control acknowledges are
recommendations for therapy and
protocols testing hiv-positive when
you're pregnant can be simply a result
of being pregnant one of the first cross
reactions on HIV tests that were ever
noted with pregnancy itself you have a
safe food
prophecy the more people are treated
against AIDS the more people will
eventually develop AIDS from it and then
the perfect excuse is to limit this the
medication you can say Jesus if I had
medicated you you would have been sick
even sooner and would've died sooner but
thanks to my medication you are only
getting sick now and we are giving you
even more education we need more money
to develop further medications that have
flipped to cure the first aids patients
the old paradigm in sciences first you
find the cause and then you treat the
cause well with eight we have violated
pulse we have assumed to cause have
never proved it we have assumed it was
infectious we have assumed among all
infectious age this virus does it we
have been unable to prove it and we have
cured and cured and cured against the
spoils mr. the side of 600,000 patients
through an 50,000 dead are not a single
cure in sight they're claiming more and
more money to continue the same vicious
cycle oh really benefits from the
billions upon billions of dollars that
each year on a dress shirt
alright so the you know there's a whole
cast of characters in this and I've
really focused a bit on Peter duesberg
because again I think he's the most
credible and the most visible for sure
so I but these snippets that I've taken
are readily available and I actually had
to spend some time sifting through what
might be most appropriate for this talk
because there are literally hundreds of
them and you can watch them yourself on
YouTube all you have to do is do a
Google search looking and what you would
look for is aids cure which is what I
think an awful lot of people use those
kinds of search terms when they test
hiv-positive who's most vulnerable to
this information people that are most
desperate to find a cure brothers
sisters as impaired intest hiv-positive
themselves people who have kids that are
hiv-positive people who want to believe
that HIV does not cause AIDS I think we
all would like to believe that that
actually HIV is harmless and if you have
these antibodies it doesn't mean that
you you have to you know go through this
you have to tell people you have to
experience stigma that we would all like
to believe that and that's an element of
denial that denialists propagate and
people who are disadvantaged
particularly people of with less
internet savvy and people who have less
treatment literacy are more vulnerable
to this information we did a study a
while back where we compared two
different pieces of information that we
found from the internet were compared
people with HIV infection over 400
people read these two snippets from the
internet and we had them rate them in
terms of their credibility unbelievably
big believability and their importance
one of these websites was from the
Journal of the American Medical
Association very credible information
and another was taken from a website
that we found that proclaimed to have a
cure for hiv/aids by
by ingesting a serum made from goat's
blood yeah come on let's go
okay okay and in that study what we did
was we had a whole bunch of factors that
we use to predict these credibility
readings and these are the credibility
ratings being predicted for the goats
blood serum snippet right and what we
found was that people with lower
education African Americans and people
who had more information avoidance and
used avoidant coping more which is
indicative of being in the somewhat
denial were predictors of raiding goats
blood serum as a credible believable
important piece of information about HIV
aids aids and I ilysm undermines our
efforts to get people tested there's no
question what they say is that the test
is invalid and they provide information
from the testing kit instructions
themselves to make that case they
undermine our efforts to treat people
these are some of the better graphics
that have actually been done by a group
called Adbusters it's a professional
advertising agency that's gotten into
this and so if not if not
antiretrovirals then then what what's
the alternative then there's no
disputing that there are millions of
people suffering from AIDS particularly
in Africa but what's the AIDS being
caused by poverty stress and
antiretrovirals so what's the
alternative good nutrition and vitamins
there are two there are a lot of
culprits in this and in my experience
over the past couple years in meeting
these people and sort of infiltrating
the group I I assumed identities and got
to know some of them and I don't really
believe that most of these guys are evil
most of them are pretty crazy but they
aren't evil these guys I think are evil
this is Gary Null he's based in New York
City and he sells vitamins and air
filters and fans and kosher foods and
books he makes movies
he is a real profiteer and he has a real
stake in undermining antiretroviral
therapies in Africa the real culprit was
Mathias wrath and he is really
responsible for assisting the South
African government in hijacking their
public health policy promoting natural
remedies Mathias wrath is a german-based
vitamin entrepreneur and we do our
research in Atlanta and there is a
buyer's club and a sort of holistic
treatment group that we've been
affiliated with actually for some time
and I asked the guy who runs that group
if he's familiar with rats products he
says so yeah we carry a lot of routes
products he sells some good stuff and so
Mathias wrath is um recent he's
conducted unlicensed unethical what he
called clinical trials along with David
raznie in South Africa and most recently
the South African highest courts have
proclaimed them illegal it's an ALICE
really are positioning themselves to try
to influence public policy they have a
real target in this part of their poster
boy quite literally is robert gallo and
april twenty third which is coming up is
rethinking aids day it's a national
holiday that they proclaimed to get
people to sort of be more aware of the
hoax that's being put on the world about
hiv/aids april 23rd commemorates the the
press conference in which robert gallo
announced the discovery of HIV that's
what's significant about april 23rd
there are events happening all over the
country actually all over the world on
april 23rd commemorating rethinking aids
day denialists have had some impact in
this way one thing that they were very
successful at doing a guy named lea
michele liam chef in New York City was
very successful in causing a whole
havoc around clinical trials that were
being done with kids and orphanages in
new york city kids that were HIV
positive and were enrolled in nih
clinical trials for pediatric
antiretroviral therapy those trials were
stopped because of the AIDS a nihilist
propaganda that chef was putting forward
and those kids were pulled out of
treatment the BBC did a documentary on
this called guinea guinea pig kids which
they ultimately recanted but they were
persuaded by the denialists that this
was a real phenomenon the BBC in
Australia and in Canada there have been
efforts to use the the science that HIV
does not necessarily cause AIDS and that
actually HIV may be harmless as a
defense in cases where people are being
prosecuted for intentionally and
knowingly exposing people to HIV after
all what's the harm and we'll celebrate
a case of this was Andre Penn zine and I
know that you think I'm kidding right
you think this is all a bunch of crap
you're saying that guy looks crazy is
that really Andre Penn zine it is that's
really him and he was prosecuted in
Australia for exposing multiple women to
HIV the AIDS Annihilus came to his
defense literally and he launched a
defense in his arm in his trial that Ida
expose anybody there's no proof is a
nihilist claim that we are all HIV
positive because if you test all of our
blood in its pure form it'll come back
positive you know you have to dilute
blood before you can test it why is that
right so if you don't dilute it
everybody's HIV positive and there have
been articles published by them in their
own concocted journals showing this
pseudo scientific experiment to be true
and this is a sign that was posted in
India all blood is HIV positive says
Roberto Geraldo who's now he's can never
figure out if he's in New York or Brazil
he kind of is in both places well who
listens to this crap right I mean it's
sort of like under the radar who really
cares what these people are saying
while Angela Hutchinson at the CDC that
it did a great little study they looked
at gay men in like five different cities
on 700 gay men and you know what forty
five percent of gay men in the United
States and five different cities agreed
with the statement HIV does not cause
AIDS where do they get that from these
are gay men supposedly the most
enlightened the most educated about HIV
and AIDS in our country right 51% said
that HIV drugs can harm you more than
help you these are purely denialists
beliefs in our own research a study that
were in the middle of right now in
Atlanta thirty-six percent of our
hiv-positive people that we're studying
in Atlanta the sample will grow to 350
but with 183 people there a third of our
people say that there is a debate among
scientists about whether HIV even causes
AIDS they agree with the statement there
is no proof that HIV causes AIDS almost
a quarter of them and a quarter of them
say that HIV treatments do more harm
than good these are HIV infected people
living in Atlanta today twelve percent
say aids can be caused by malnutrition
even if you don't have HIV infection in
a survey done with in houston with 113
hiv-positive people sixty-three percent
endorsed at least one of several
conspiracy beliefs such as HIV was
released on purpose by the government
the nihilism and conspiracy theories and
pseudoscience are all in the same pod
almost 1,500 men and women living in
houston won in five of them believe that
aids is an agent of genocide created by
the US government to kill off minority
populations and in the best study like
this Laura Bogart who's now at Harvard
did a nationally representative sample
of african-americans in a random digit
dial nationally representative sample
kind of a study and she found that seven
percent seven percent of
african-americans national represent
sample so the medicine doctors
prescribed to treat HIV as poison
forty-three percent say people who take
new medicines for HIV are really human
guinea pigs for the government almost
half now of course we've earned that
legacy in public health right we can't
forget about the legacy of Tuskegee what
is influencing in the seeds that are
planted that helped denialism broke in
South Africa Laura Bogart has found that
forty-two percent of STD clinic patients
very high risk for HIV infection many of
them hiv-infected themselves forty-two
percent say that medicines for AIDS do
more harm than good and patients who
hold these generous Idol beliefs are
less likely to get tested for HIV it
hasn't these beliefs have an impact on
behavior and no where do we see that
more than in South Africa okay the
legacy of denialism in South Africa
which always gets everyone's attention I
think we're doing a lot of harm here but
in South Africa it was devastating in
year two thousand the year that the AIDS
Conference was in South Africa the South
African president my becky became very
convinced that there is a legitimate
debate among scientists excellent
scientists who don't agree and on his
presidential panel he split it he
created a facade of debate half of the
scientists were AIDS Annihilus half of
the scientists were among the best
scientists and AIDS in the world
interestingly enough the credible aid
scientists were mostly South African
most of the denialists were American and
European white guys unbelievable and
these are the real players in AIDS
denialism and you know it's been a point
of incredible controversy even after the
resignation of the former president
table met Becky in South Africa these
are two great cartoons from the probably
the best political cartoonist of our
times appear oh there you have the
presidential aides panel led by the Mad
Hatter and there you have the the health
minister of South
Africa at the time up until just until
September of 2008 holding back the sea
of AIDS science at the durban conference
so there's no mystery what was going on
there right but what was happening was
as as this sort of pseudo debate went on
antiretrovirals were withheld from South
Africans and the effects are very clear
the life expectancy in South Africa
declined just as it did everywhere else
in Africa despite South Africa's better
economy better standard of living and
their of their ability to have been
providing medications and why is that
because AIDS is caused by poverty well
you know South Africa's poverty isn't
nearly as robust as poverty in perhaps
let's say Bangladesh where there's
hardly any AIDS at all but in South
Africa which is the most resource
country in Africa AIDS is quite
prevalent and here we see a graphic that
shows the decline of poverty the
increase in standard of living the
decline in poverty in South Africa over
the same period of time that aids was
accumulating and still is recent Monica
mathematical modeling at Harvard has you
know concluded that over 350,000 South
Africans died as a result of the AIDS
denialism and withholding antiretroviral
therapy and the and the pushback on
prevention it's been shown that during
this time whereas Brazil and South
Africa started out in the same place in
terms of their aides epidemics Brazil
started preventing and treating right
away and South Africa did not and we see
the devastation in South Africa far
greater that's that solid red line then
the the South African epidemic in 97
compared to the Brazil epidemic in 2004
and we see it in perinatal transmission
I'm a Muslim we see it in perinatal
transmission okay in New York State it's
very rare now for a baby to be born with
HIV
infection in Botswana a country much
poorer than South Africa we see a
perinatal HIV transmission much much
declined much more like New York now but
in South Africa more than 35,000 South
African pediatric HIV infections could
have been prevented with the
administration of antiretrovirals but it
was withheld so what do we do about it
then what are what can we can kind of
conclude deny aids and I ilysm exists
and it I in my view it's growing mostly
as the Internet becomes more accessible
there is no longer a digital divide so
my suggestions are that we don't ignore
it when you see it you address it we
have as aid scientists and practitioners
we've ignored AIDS denialism and said I
was just a bunch of coups and crazies if
we ignore them they'll go away that
hasn't happened we should not debate
with AIDS Annihilus it hits the
impression that there is a debate and we
are really inclined to do that I'll show
them they're wrong you cannot win a
debate with an AIDS Annihilus because
they're not playing by the rules they're
not going to yield the facts there's
always an answer and there are tactics
like moving the goalposts and cherry
picking their real tactics that are
associated with denialism and not just
for AIDS and I think that we should
really expose aids annales for what they
are and what they really are is is
frauds and entrepreneurs and egocentric
academics and angry old men and that's
what we should really be I think
exposing them as we should teach
Internet critical thinking skills to our
participants in our clients they should
be able to separate the crap from the
good stuff we should get involved in
AIDS education it is a myth that we
don't need to do that anymore because
we've been doing it for so long what's
tiring about AIDS is it's a new
generation all the time the gay men of
today that are you know 18 to 24 didn't
get the AIDS education of the 90s we
should as scientists a
actively communicate our research
findings and we are really piss poor at
this we're really bad at it and and then
the media even can misconstrue our
miscommunicated findings worse and that
gives Annihilus the opportunity to
cherry-pick things that just aren't true
and we really should promote aid science
literacy and that's what's great about
AIDS science day is it's a contributing
factor to promoting aid science literacy
so let me tell you that there's a book
that I wrote that's my whole experience
about this and I I actually am find it
distasteful to promote books like I got
a book to sell but what's cool about
denying aids and why I am shamelessly
promoting it it's fizzy envia
antiretrovirals the royalties are being
donated to buy antiretrovirals in Africa
mostly because I figured that would
really get the night out of piss off so
there are 22 there's one great website
that is really on top of the whole AIDS
Annihilus issue it's called AIDS truth
org it is the anti rethinking aids
website and then I created an author's
blog actually that has been getting a
bit of a bit of play I've been kind of
it's been kind of a cool experience to
have a blog the denying aids dot
blogspot com is my way to sort of keep
people posted on what's happening in
aids and I ilysm because there seems to
be something new every day thank you
very much oh and I books for sale in the
back corner books for sale in the back
corner and royalties
I guess there's little time for
questions comments or question all right
well I think we got one here you can
have to really yell it I may not be able
to hear you
yeah and the real deal here is that it's
a mixed bag okay so I correspondent with
a number of these guys over a year year
and a half period I I went to a meeting
and I met Peter duesberg and David
rasnick and so I actually feel like I
did sort of get get to know some of them
fairly well and it's just a real mixed
bag and and you know I mean for example
with Peter duesberg there's a lot of
people who have written and say the
Peter duesberg is essentially
fundamentally a narcissist and I think
that there are some truth to that but
there is no question i have no doubt in
my mind at all that Peter duesberg
really believes that a that everything
he says that he's not just sort of lying
he's not a psychopath he's trying to
cause harm he really believes it Peter
duesberg I had him sign a copy of his
book for me have you don't know what's
me but for me and he looking dead square
in the eyes I was three inches from him
and he said you know this is not an
infectious disease there's no vaccine
for this and I he really believes it
okay and so there's that you know
there's there's there's a sort of
narcissistic blinded kind of academic
who's really entrenched in his own anger
and bitterness and and I think that's
true for him and a few others then there
are others who have something to sell
like the rafts and and the nulls and
then there are others who are really
kind of gravitated towards this as
libertarians so there's a there's a
strong movement within a zone I ilysm
that are actually libertarians the
political group you know the Ron Paul
types who say you know what the
government is basically screwed and you
can't trust anything the government says
and this whole Gallo thing was a
government fiasco that was really
underwritten by the pharmaceutical
industry conspiracy thinkers so it's a
real mixed bag you can't say that there
is one thing but you know what they
don't concern me they actually I don't
really they don't concern me it's the
people that might be listening to them
that concern me the people who test
hiv-positive are looking for information
and our confuse
it's like what Jim Curran said just when
people need good information is when
these guys try to confuse them with bad
information